une émission ça paye en pense quoi
camille sée on a vraiment joué cet été
le type de l'émission opinion mais
stefan van comme ce fut le cas avec
l'iphone y la raquette je dis voilà on
joue le titre de ton émission moi j'aime
bien il en pense quoi camille lui l'aimé
autre chose et j'ai gagné au smartphone
et dont c'était quoi il en titre ils en
pensent quoi mathieu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je viens de loin je suis heureux
d'être là avec vous ce soir jean marc
généreux
non non c'est pas trouvé c'est qui mais
en attendant une bouilloire htc votre
avis on est au studio mon époque
1 comment vous la pluie bon je l'appelle
mhd par son nom de scène mais je sais
être avisé sait pas de quel je sais que
certains sont annoncés sur ses initiales
c'est quoi ce nom alors mouloud
[Rires]